تمكنت أكبر 10 صناديق ثروة سيادية في منطقة الخليج
مجتمعة من إدارة ما يقرب من
أربعة تريليونات دولار، وهو رقم كبير
قد يبدو جذابًا للمستثمرين، ويمكن
رؤية مثال على ذلك من خلال شركة
Sanibel Investments، ذراع صندوق الاستثمار العام الاستثماري، التي
كشفت عن تعاونها مع ما يقرب من
40 شركة VCS أمريكية بما في ذلك أسماء مثل
Andreessen Horowitz Tiger.  شركة Global
Management وأحد شركات رأس المال الاستثماري التكنولوجي التي
تستثمر في المنطقة منذ عام 2012 ولها
موظفون في الرياض ودبي 500 Global
من بين أولئك الذين يستثمرون في المنطقة
المستثمر المعروف مارك موبيوس وهو
شخصية رئيسية في تطوير
السياسات الدولية في الأسواق الناشئة وسجله
يُظهر أنه استثمر في أكثر من 5000
شركة حول العالم وأدار
أصولًا بقيمة 40 مليار دولار.
التقيت به مؤخرًا لمعرفة سبب
انجذاب المستثمرين الدوليين بشكل متزايد إلى الخليج، ما هي
توقعاتك لمنطقة دول مجلس التعاون الخليجي في
حد ذاتها الآن؟  مع الأرقام
التي صادفتها جيدًا، فإن
أحد
الأشياء العظيمة التي حدثت
بالطبع هو أنهم يجذبون الأشخاص
من جميع أنحاء العالم وكانوا
انتقائيين للغاية حيث يحاولون الحصول على
أفضل الأشخاص تعليمًا والذين
يرغبون في الاستثمار، وهذه طريقة ذكية جدًا
للقيام بذلك لجذب أشخاص جدد إلى
المنطقة، لذا أعتقد أنه من
المثير للاهتمام أن دبي قد مهدت
الطريق نوعًا ما كمثال والآن
ترى جميع البلدان  في الشرق
الأوسط، انظر إلى دبي وقل ربما
ينبغي لنا أن نفعل نفس الشيء، فأنت تقول إن
المملكة العربية السعودية الآن تتحرك بسرعة كبيرة في
هذا الاتجاه، وقد اتبعتها جميع الإمارات
أيضًا، لذا فإن الأمر
مثير للغاية وأعتقد أنه سيكون كذلك  من
المثير للاهتمام للغاية ما هو السوق الذي يثير اهتمامك أكثر
في المنطقة بصرف النظر عما تراه
في الإمارات العربية المتحدة والشراء على وجه التحديد
بالطبع، عليك أن تبدأ بالمملكة العربية
السعودية لأنها سوق كبيرة وكبيرة
ولديها مخزون أكثر سيولة ولكن  لقد قمت
مؤخرًا بزيارة أبو ظبي، وكان
لديهم سوق نشط للغاية وبالطبع
دبي جيدة جدًا، ونحن بحاجة
إلى رؤية المزيد من السيولة ودخول
الشركات الأكبر إلى السوق
والتطور الأكثر إثارة للاهتمام هو عدد
هذه الشركات المملوكة عائليًا
بدأوا يدركون أنه يتعين عليهم
الاستعداد للجيل القادم ولكن هذا
سيكون تطورًا مثيرًا للاهتمام للغاية من
الآن فصاعدا. هل تعتقد
أننا نرى زخمًا فيما يتعلق
بقدوم شركات رأس المال في نهاية المطاف إلى
المنطقة أيضًا، نعم من
المثير للاهتمام حقًا أن نرى  كيف
كانت الحكومات تجتذب
شركات رأس المال الاستثماري هذه من خلال تزويدها برأس
المال للاستثمار فيه في المنطقة؟
أعتقد أن هذا تطور مهم للغاية،
وهناك الكثير من
رواد الأعمال الذين تعرفهم في الشرق
الأوسط، هناك تقليد
لريادة الأعمال والتجارة و
يمكن الآن لشركات رأس المال الاستثماري هذه أن تأتي
وتستثمر في هذه المؤسسات
وتحقق أداءً جيدًا للغاية في المستقبل، لذا
أعتقد أنه سيكون تطورًا جيدًا للغاية
وسيحظى بتشجيع من
حكومات المنطقة
الأجنبية